DIANE SOLINGER: Hi, everybody.
I'm Diane Solinger.
I'm the Manager of the
Googler's Give team.
We're the team in Google
in People Operations
that helps Googlers volunteer
and give to charitable causes
and impact issues
that they care about,
whether it's in their back
yard, around the world.
And today is World Food Day.
It's a day that is focused,
obviously, on food,
but it's really focused in a lot
of ways on the absence of food.
And that's why today is
also launching our team,
Googlers Give and the
[INAUDIBLE] food team
are launching the
Hunger Relief campaign.
This campaign is
in its third year.
We're pretty excited to work
in partnership with our food
team that is all
about food, to try
to help people that
don't have food,
and particular focus
on children who
are on the brink of starvation.
Today it's talking
a little bit more
about the global picture of
hunger and hunger relief,
but also about what's
happening in our own community
here in the Bay area where
Google is headquartered.
We're really fortunate
to have representatives
from Stop Hunger Now, which has
been a great partner for Google
and Googlers.
Many Googlers have been
volunteering with Stop Hunger
Now over the course
of the past two years.
And we've been
volunteering to pack food,
like this, which we'll
show you later, and send
to schools and
children, particularly
around the world who are really
not getting the nutrition
that they need.
Their model is unique,
and Rod will tell us
a little bit about that.
We also have the Second Harvest
Food Bank with us today,
which has been a
partner of Google
for a very, very long time.
Many of you know Alan Eustace,
our Senior Vice President
of Knowledge.
He works very closely,
annually, with the food bank
to do a very fun extravaganza
at Costco in Mountain View.
And that event just keeps
getting bigger and bigger.
And what we've seen not just
with the Second Harvest Food
Bank, but with food
banks around the world,
Googlers are getting
more involved
in trying to help their local
communities with food security
issues for people
in their hometowns.
So we're going to start with a
bit of an overview, World Food
Day, what's the
landscape out there
and what is the face of hunger,
and it looks very different
depending on where
you live in the world.
If you are in
Nicaragua, which we'll
hear from Eddy and Jennifer
about their experiences
in Nicaragua, it's going to
look very different to maybe
what it looks like
here in East Palo
Alto or the East
side of San Jose.
But hunger is real.
There are over
800 million people
in the world that don't
get enough to eat.
And yet, we know there's
enough food for everybody.
We're just not
getting it to people.
You think of climate
change and how
that's affecting the ability for
people to grow crops in the way
that they used to.
And we were just talking
about even the drought
here in California.
We've got to think
about how we farm
and what our natural
resources are going to be like
as climate change affects that.
So what does that mean
to the small farmer who
is reliant on just
rainfall and doesn't
have the systems in place
to get water to their farms?
And how does that
trickle down, literally,
to their families
and their children?
And then what does
that mean systemically
for kids that don't have
nutrition, whether it's
in a local school or in
Nicaragua and can't learn?
What happens then?
So food is the basic need--
food, water, shelter.
Think about the basic thing
that people need, we need food.
And not enough people
are getting the food
that we actually currently have,
and then in the future what
is that going to look like
when climate change affects us,
or other instances that
we can't even predict.
But food is a basic
need, and that's
what World Food Day is about.
That's what the Hunger
Relief Campaign is about.
And that's what these two
great organizations are about.
So I'm going to kick it
over to Rod Brooks who's
the CEO of Stop Hunger Now.
It's based in North
Carolina, but the history
of this organization
is pretty fascinating.
And as you'll notice with both
these organizations, Second
Harvest and Stop Hunger
Now, there's a plate
and there's some utensils
around both of their logos.
So it's [INAUDIBLE] let's
get that food in you.
But the history of Stop Hunger
Now is really interesting
because food banking
was a part of it.
But then where you've
evolved, and just
give us the high level
scope of the view
that you have with
your organization
on the hunger issue.
ROD BROOKS: I will.
Well, thank you, Diane,
really, for inviting
us to be a part of this
event, and for kicking off
this hunger campaign that
you're initiating today.
As we get started here, I
want to invite everyone just
to let you know that we will
be entertaining your questions.
So we have some things
to share with you today,
but really we're hoping
this can be a conversation.
We invite your questions.
So be thinking
about what you might
ask at the end of
our presentation.
But I wanted to start to
just first by giving you
some more information sort
of from the global view
about world hunger.
Diane just shared some
information with you.
Right now there are, in
fact, 805 million people
around the world who
are malnourished,
who suffer from hunger
on a daily basis.
That's one in every nine of us.
Now, think about it.
If one in nine of
us in this room
were malnourished, didn't
have the food they need,
would there be any
other priority?
Would there be
any other priority
than making sure that
those individuals had food.
That's a question we
have to ask ourselves.
Of the 805 million
that suffer from hunger
every single day,
about 25,000 a day
die from hunger and
hunger-related causes.
That number is astounding to me.
Particularly, as you
mentioned, Diane,
when there's enough
food in the world
to feed every single person.
40% of those suffering
from hunger are children.
Why is it that children
have to die every single day
from the lack of
food when there's
enough food to feed everyone.
That is really why we're having
this conversation here today.
As we think about
those numbers, it's
easy to get depressed
or a little more
than challenged, frankly,
overwhelmed sometimes.
But there's actually some good
news to share around these,
and that is in the
progress that we're
making towards ending hunger.
So the United Nations
just recently announced
its annual Hunger State
of Food Insecurity Report,
and there's good news,
actually, to share
in the progress we're making
towards ending hunger.
What that report showed
was that that 805 million
who suffer from hunger
today is actually
100 million people less
than the number that
suffered from
hunger 10 years ago.
So in one decade we've
reduced the number
of malnourished people in the
world by 100 million people.
If you go back further than
that, we've actually since 1992
we've reduced the number
of malnourished people
by more than 200 million people.
That's remarkable.
Especially when you think
about the population growth
that we've seen
during that time.
So when you look at the
prevalence of hunger
around the world, you actually
see that in 1992 there
were just under
19% of the world's
population were malnourished.
Because of the advances, the
progress that we've seen,
that percentage is just
over 11% now, 11.3%.
That's remarkable
progress, and truly it's
something to give us hope.
We have 63 countries
that have actually
met the first Millennium
development goal.
That was to cut hunger
in half by the year 2015.
63 countries that have
already made that happen.
That gives us hope, in fact,
that we can do that worldwide.
We can meet that first
Millennium development goal
worldwide by 2015.
We have the
opportunity to do that.
That goal is within reach.
It will take some extra work,
because we're reducing hunger
at the rate of about half a
percentage point per year.
So we need to step up
our efforts a little bit,
but that goal is very
much within reach.
So there's good news,
but while there's
good news in the
progress, we need
to understand what's
making that possible,
and we need to not lose
focus because hunger
is a very local issue.
And I think you'll hear
that today, that hunger is
a very local issue,
and in some cases,
the numbers aren't
getting better.
So we need to learn from
what we've done well
in the successes
that we've seen,
but we have to keep that at
focus and that commitment
to actually ending
hunger in our lifetime.
So I will just share briefly
what Stop Hunger Now is doing.
In fact, our roots do come
from domestic hunger relief.
Our Founder Ray
Buchanan helped found
the Society of St. Andrew, which
was one of the original meal
gleaning organizations.
But in 1998, his focus
turned international
as he realized the need to
address international hunger
relief.
Initially our focus
was on crisis response.
But very quickly you
learn that the disasters
that we read about-- the
earthquakes, the tsunamis,
the famine brought about
by war, et cetera-- that's
only a small portion
of the hunger that
exists in the world.
In fact, the real
need is to address
the chronic malnutrition
that exists.
And so what Stop Hunger
Now began doing around 2005
was working to address
chronic malnutrition.
And we learned that one
of the most effective ways
to address chronic malnutrition
in developing countries
is school feeding programs.
So we initiated a
meal packaging program
where volunteers, like the many
Googlers who have participated
with us, they come together
and package these high protein
dehydrated meals.
These meals have rice,
soy, dehydrated vegetables,
and a specially formulated
vitamin formulation
that is designed for
malnourished individuals,
to give them the
micronutrients that they
need to overcome the
effects of hunger.
So volunteers come together
and package these meals.
Then we provide
them to partners--
we work with partners in
more than 40 countries now.
And to date, we're serving
about 400,000 people a day
using our meals.
DIANE SOLINGER: The
distribution model
of the schools I think
is really, really
a special thing that you
guys do extraordinarily well.
ROD BROOKS: Well,
and that's the issue.
There are many ways that these
meals could be distributed.
What we're trying to do
is to really leverage
the distribution that
we have, to provide
not only an immediate impact,
but really a long term impact.
Now, let me say more about that.
So of course, when you start
a school feeding program
you're providing
the immediate immed
that children need, to learn.
You'll hear in a moment how
it's really impossible to learn.
You can't think, concentrate,
on an empty belly.
But also what we find is when we
start a school feeding program,
those meals act is a
tremendous incentive
for parents to send their
children to school, knowing
that they'll get a hot meal.
What does that do, as school
enrollment rates increase
dramatically--
sometimes we've seen
double, triple, quadruple or
more-- literacy rates increase.
Vocational training
opportunities are present.
Through that education,
children have hope.
And it's through that
education that we
can begin to break the
cycle of poverty that
so often keeps
hunger in existence.
DIANE SOLINGER: Let's take
that a little bit further
because we have Eddy here, and
Eddy is from an organization
called ORPHANetwork
in Nicaragua that
is a distribution partner
of Stop Hunger Now.
And we were talking just
a couple minutes ago,
Eddy, that I found
Nicaragua is excited
that they're having five years
of education as the average.
And trying to get to
six years of education
for the average citizen
in their country.
So does a food program
through schools
help people think that OK,
we can stay in school longer.
Is it going to help meet
that goal of getting kids
to have six years of
education, of formal education?
EDDY MORALES: Yes.
That's right.
Thank you for inviting
us, also, from Nicaragua.
It's so good to be
here and to share
what we're doing in Nicaragua
and how things are changing.
So for Jennifer,
Leyla and myself,
it's so exciting to be here.
And yes.
And then personally
work with them
with a school feeding program.
I remember when I started, we
were feeding 56,000 children,
and grow the program up to one
million children every day.
DIANE SOLINGER:
That's incredible.
Wow.
EDDY MORALES: And the big thing
there was more than growing
the number is creating
hope for these children,
creating opportunities
for these children
for a way of broken
cycles of poverty,
knowing the life
of these children.
And yes, when the parents know
that there is no foot home,
but at the school
there is food, and then
teachers can take
advantage of that,
know to then work
with the children
in the field of
education, that's amazing.
And that is happening
in Nicaragua.
And today we are serving
with our partners.
We are serving 18,000
children in Nicaragua.
And one of the big indicators
that we're working on
is education.
So we really want our
kids to go to school.
It's more than the meal.
The meal is a way of probably
bringing hope and telling them
yes, it's possible.
Yes, we can make it happen.
Yes, we're going to feed you.
There will be a meal, but what
we want you to go to school.
Because at the end of the
day, what is going to make
a difference in their life
is not the meal itself,
but including education to that.
And actually, that's our story.
Leyla, myself, and
me, that's our story.
Education is what change
our life, what took us out
of poverty.
DIANE SOLINGER: Before we go
to Jennifer who has that story,
how did you guys find
each other as partners?
ROD BROOKS: Well--
[LAUGHTER]
DIANE SOLINGER: Do you Google?
Did you Google it?
ROD BROOKS: So we
initiated our program
and we had been working
with a number of partners
around the world
providing crisis response,
and then as we initiated
the meal packaging program,
we found that certain partners
who were receiving meals
from us would refer
other partners.
Once the meals get out
there, people find you.
And I think that was the
case with ORPHANetwork.
It was, in fact, one
of our staff members
had traveled to Nicaragua
through her church.
And it was through
Chessney Barrick,
who had a direct experience
with ORPHANetwork,
who said, you know, this
is a group that we really
ought to try to help.
She was so moved by the work
that Eddy and ORPHANetwork
was doing.
And I just have to
brag, by the way.
When we talk about
ending hunger,
we're really serious about that.
And I think ORPHANetwork is
one of the best examples where,
as Eddy mentioned,
they're feeding
18,000 children every day.
Well, in four years, the rate of
malnutrition among those 18,000
children has dropped from 27%
to 12%-- more than cut in half.
And that is remarkable.
EDDY MORALES: And
that's the work
the churches and partners
and friends and doctors
and everyone is
doing in Nicaragua.
We are so focused on result.
It's sort of
result-based management.
So we said, man, by
feeding the children
only we are not going
to make a difference.
So what if we can work
on some indicators
and work towards those.
So one of our indicator
three years ago
was to wipe out malnutrition.
And that's what we're
working towards.
The idea is wipe
out malnutrition.
We always say every
community we put one step in,
we want to wipe out
malnutrition while we're
sending the kids
to school, also.
DIANE SOLINGER: That's
kind of step one.
EDDY MORALES: Yeah.
So the numbers, as Rod said,
number has gone from 26%,
actually, to 12%.
This year we're going to end,
or we're working really hard
to end this year with 8%.
And in some communities
it's already
down to 3%, 2%, and yes.
DIANE SOLINGER: And
are you distributed
throughout the country
or are you focused
strictly in Nicaragua?
EDDY MORALES: No, we are in
almost 14 states or departments
out of 18, roughly.
And the idea is to
reach the country, also.
DIANE SOLINGER: That's amazing.
So Jennifer, you've
been a recipient
of Stop Hunger Now
and ORPHANetwork.
Tell us about your
story, because now you're
in university.
JENNIFER: Yes, I'm a sophomore.
DIANE SOLINGER: Perfect.
JENNIFER: Actually, I would
have five years in college,
so I guess I'll
be a senior twice.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, I'm 18 years old, and
I was raised in an orphanage.
My mom-- well, my father left
us when I was three years old,
and my mom didn't have enough
money to make ends meet.
So I just learned that
phrase, "ends meet."
I like it.
So she put us in the
orphanage because-- me,
and my brother-- my oldest
brother-- and of course,
I was destroyed at first.
I just couldn't understand
why I was in there.
I mean why?
And at first, I got sick.
Seeing as I was sick,
I wouldn't eat--
not that the food was bad,
just that I was so depressed.
My only consolation
was my brother.
I just didn't know why
she was leaving us there.
But then, through time, I got to
understand why was the reason.
And I got to love the place
because through time, I
thought of the place as my home.
It's just that it was a
huge home with 80 kids that
were like my
brother and sisters,
and my caregivers
were my parents.
So I got to know that it was in
God's plan for me to be there.
And to be here with you now,
to be sharing this testimony
with you, because it
was awesome, seriously.
My childhood was as, I
think all the same as you.
I got to play a lot.
I always have tons of energy.
And I went to school.
I had good grades, because
I had good caregivers that
were always helping me and
were always encouraging me.
And because they bet on me.
And when somebody
bet on you, you're
like how can you
disappoint that person?
And it's the same
with all of you.
You have bet on us,
because you're working,
you are helping us, you're
willing to do something for us.
Like hunger, the Stop
Hunger Now and ORPHANetwork,
they bet on us.
And that's encouraging,
because you say,
wow, these people
are not my parents,
that didn't know
anything about me
went I arrive at the orphanage.
They welcome me.
They hug me, they kiss me.
They treat me as
their own child.
And when you see
all that, you want
to do that, you want
to be part of that.
You want to be
someone like Eddy.
I still think that I want
to take your position.
I want to continue
that legacy, you know.
I want to keep working
with child-- I love childs.
Although sometimes
they drive me crazy.
I just love to be
with childs and youth,
and to be able to be there
for them as all of you
have been there for me.
Because I think of all
of you as my family.
When I arrived at
the orphanage, I
was like only my brother--
brother come here, please.
Be with me.
But then I have
now many friends.
I mean tons of friends in there.
And it was great
to experience that.
It was great to have home
and roof, food to eat.
Because when you don't have
food, and you go to school,
you're like going on empty
stomach, you can't think,
you can't reason.
You probably have bad
grades because you
don't have something
in your stomach.
And it's, oh, my
gosh, I'm so hungry.
You cannot think
about anything else.
But I was glad I had food.
I remember I was telling
someone yesterday
that one time, when I was
maybe 10 or 11, the caregivers
were going to fast.
And I said, OK, I
want to do that, too.
And they say, OK, do
know what is that?
I was like, no.
And then they explain
what in was to me.
I say, OK, wait.
We pray to God.
We don't eat all
day until dinner.
I say, OK, I'm going to do that.
I have a reason to do it.
But after school, I
came to the orphanage
and I was crying and crying,
and my brother came to me.
He was like, what's the matter?
What's up?
I was like, I'm
so hungry, I said.
And he say, well, go eat.
I said I can't.
I'm fasting.
And he said, don't be crazy.
God will understand you.
He knows what you need.
I was like, wow.
I mean any other
person could say, well,
I don't have nowhere
to go to eat.
But I did.
I knew that I could
go to the kitchen
and ask the cookers to
give me something to eat.
I was like, wow, this is great.
I felt very lucky to be there.
DIANE SOLINGER: Just like we
were all saying, it's step one.
JENNIFER: Exactly.
DIANE SOLINGER: Making sure
that there's food security.
And for us who pack these
wonderful packages of food
and ship them off to we don't
know where sometimes, it's
really nice to see that it
gets from you to you to you,
and now you're thinking
about-- as I said earlier,
paying it forward.
You're going to go
back and try to help
and I think that's
a wonderful circle.
Thank you.
And food security,
that term, it's
an issue here in the Bay area.
It's an issue in
the developed world.
And we talk about children
going to school hungry
here in the Bay area, and that's
just not acceptable anywhere.
So Kathy, tell us about
Second Harvest Mission.
What you do for the
counties that you support,
and overall food banking,
if people don't understand
even the concept of that maybe.
KATHY JACKSON: OK, great.
Well, I want you guys to
know that the only reason I'm
wearing logo-wear instead
of my Buster Posey Jersey
is because I knew I was
going to be on camera,
and I didn't want to
preserve for the ages.
But I would like to
talk about three things.
I'd like to talk a little bit
about the business of hunger.
I want to talk a little bit
about what hunger looks like
here in Silicon Valley.
And I want to talk a
little bit about what
Second Harvest is
doing about it, OK?
DIANE SOLINGER: Sounds good.
KATHY JACKSON: So why
would I use a weird phrase
like the business of hunger?
The reason I refer
to it that way
is that we're all about data
at Second Harvest Food Bank.
We're focused on data.
We're focused on metrics.
We're focused on efficiency.
I came to this work after
20 years in for-profit,
and I don't know any other way
to run a business, honestly.
So when we start looking at our
two counties, and we serve--
we're the only food bank in
Santa Clara and San Mateo
county.
Food banking is not
a competitive sport.
We're not competing
with anybody.
But when we start looking at
where the pockets of hunger
are, we start with income.
And the State of California
says that a family of four
needs $82,000 here
to make ends meet.
84% of our clients are
getting by on a household
income of $20,000 or less.
So try to imagine living on
something like $15,000 here.
I mean it blows
your mind, really.
I don't know how people do it.
But we start, we map where
the pockets of low income are.
And then we overlay on that.
We overlay all of
our 330 partners,
and 770 different food
distribution points.
We overlay on that our
particularly strong partners
who could grow and
help us do more.
And we overlay on that
food stamp penetration
rates, because the more
people utilize food stamps who
actually qualify
for that program,
it will leverage our resources.
And what happens is
then you find gaps.
You find areas
that are saturated
in terms of a lot
of food coming in,
even if there's a lot of need.
And we use that
analysis to figure out
where we're going to go,
where we need more services,
how we maximize our
ROI, how we drive
impact on this critical problem.
DIANE SOLINGER: Similar to the
whole thing, even that mapping,
there's food, it's just
maybe in the wrong places.
KATHY JACKSON: Exactly.
Exactly.
So what does hunger
look like here?
I suspect you guys see
faces of hunger every day,
but you probably don't know
it because it looks different
here.
Second Harvest Food
Bank provides food
to a quarter of a million
people every month.
That's one in 10 people
in these two counties
get some of their food
from the food bank.
So they're cafeteria workers.
They may be preschool teachers.
They may be somebody who waits
on you in a hardware store.
If you know an adult that's
trying to live on minimum wage,
even minimum wage in Mountain
View, which might go to $15,
that's only a little
over $30,000 a year.
You cannot make ends meet here.
I heard such a strange
story the other day,
and I loved it
because it emphasized
the nuance of hunger.
It's a mom, a single
mom with three kids,
and she works part-time
at an hourly job.
But her eldest son
had to go to work
to make ends meet
for the family.
He was in high school.
Now, the good news
is he graduated.
I mean that's a
fantastic outcome.
And bear in mind,
he was not working
so he'd have money to go
to the movies and stuff
with his friends.
He was working to contribute
to the household income.
But he couldn't go to his
high school graduation.
Well, why not?
Because he was afraid
to ask for the time off.
He doesn't have FTO.
He doesn't have benefits.
And that money was too
critical to his family.
And the mom when she was
telling the story, cried.
And she said, I'm a
failure as a parent.
I mean I'm so proud
of my son, but what
should have been one of
the best days of his life
was not because I can't
provide for my family.
That's what hunger looks
like here in the Bay area.
And the coping strategies that
people use, they're amazing,
and actually, quite creative.
They eat a lot of soup.
They water down their milk.
They eat food past
its expiration date.
If they're parents,
they probably
skip meals so that
their kids don't
have to go to school hungry.
Almost half the people
we serve tell us
they've traded off
educational expenses
to be able to afford food.
That might mean they
didn't have a backpack,
they didn't have basic
stuff that their kid
needed for school.
It might mean they had to defer
college or take fewer courses
because they couldn't afford it.
So what are we doing about it?
Unfortunately, we have
to be a big business.
We provide the equivalent of
a million meals every week
to people in Santa Clara
and San Mateo counties.
We've got to be vast, we've
got to be incredibly efficient,
and squeeze every dollar
as hard as we can.
But what we're realizing
is that if we really
want to move the
needle on local hunger,
we've got to go
neighborhood by neighborhood
and block by block.
And we work with 330
other non-profits
to try to do that, to
really have an impact.
We have a lot of
strategies around schools.
And I'll tell you another story.
Three weeks ago, we got
a call from a principal
at Fair Oaks Elementary School.
It's in Redwood City.
I think you guys are going to
be pretty big in Redwood City
soon.
He called in panic mode.
He said, I have never
seen poverty like this.
I was sent here to improve
educational outcomes.
I've got to get these kids fed.
There is no way
I can do anything
until we address that
fundamental need.
So it's so similar to
your experience overseas.
And yet, this is Silicon Valley.
How could this be?
So of course, we're
addressing that.
And we can talk later
about other strategies
with other schools.
It's not just public schools.
We're supporting Rocketship.
We're supporting
all kinds of schools
throughout the Bay area--
DIANE SOLINGER: Charter school.
KATHY JACKSON: --a charter
school in different ways.
We also don't look much
like a traditional food bank
at Second Harvest.
We're not about food
past its expiry date.
We're not about dented
cans of SpaghettiOs.
More than half of the
food we distribute
is fresh fruits vegetables.
We distribute milk, and eggs,
and chicken, and peanut butter,
and rice, and beans.
And we do it in a dignified way.
So I guess at the
end of the day,
I would say about
hunger here locally,
it's not a supply chain problem.
Even though we're
efficiency obsessed,
that is not what
local hunger is.
Local hunger is personal.
Local hunger is really scary for
the people who experience it.
Local hunger was
the little boy who,
when his teacher said, "What's
your favorite food for dinner,"
said, "Dinner?
Is that the meal that some
families eat in the evening?
My family doesn't
eat that meal."
You guys, hunger is solvable.
Hunger is solvable here.
And we really appreciate
our partnership with Google
to ensure that anyone who
needs a meal can get one.
DIANE SOLINGER: Thanks, Kathy.
And Suzanne, so you've
been listening to this
and getting more
involved as a Googler
and joining the board of the
Second Harvest Food Bank.
I'd love to learn
more about your path
to finding Second Harvest and
why you got so passionate--
obviously, when you listen
to Kathy, you're like, OK,
we're all in, right?
SUZANNE: Absolutely.
DIANE SOLINGER: It's certainly
a compelling mission.
We know-- I keep saying,
it's just a basic need.
We need to make sure
that people can eat.
But for you, you took a big
step in joining the board,
so tell us about that
and why you chose?
SUZANNE: Absolutely.
So as Kathy said,
the face of hunger
looks somewhat different here.
So my personal experience--
or my experience with hunger
has been very personal.
When I was little
girl, my father
owned a construction
company, and my mom
helped out with that company.
My brother passed away
very unexpectedly,
and my father was devastated.
He became addicted to drugs,
and we lost our company,
we lost our home,
we lost everything.
So my mother-- it was no
longer safe for us to stay.
So my mother moved
us to a shelter.
And that was my first
experience with food,
or I guess food scarcity.
I absolutely hated it.
It was really scary.
I missed my clothes,
and my toys,
and my house, and
my friends, and not
being able to decide what
snack you wanted to eat,
and it was really foreign.
From there, my mom tried to
get a job and she couldn't.
So she took night classes
to learn shorthand
to become a secretary.
And during that time,
we had no income.
So we received food stamps, we
received actual bags of food.
And very similarly, as much
as I was thankful for it,
I really hated that our
money looked different
from other people's money.
I became very, very
good at mental math,
because it was incredibly
embarrassing to stand
in line at the grocery store
and put item by item back.
And it was really hard to
watch my mom get so upset when
we had to do that.
And so we're really
lucky, right?
I mean obviously I'm
sitting here at Google.
My mom was eventually
able to get a job.
She worked for all of my years
growing up, two or three jobs,
so that I could really
focus on my education, which
is what got me here.
But it's never something
that really leaves you.
I mean it probably was three
years ago where I finally
stopped sorting my items in my
cart at Target, like the ones
I had to buy and the ones
I maybe wanted to get.
And so I think the
metric that-- being
at Google and data
driven-- the metric that
has been so powerful
for me is one
in three children in
the Bay area is hungry.
And I don't know about you
guys, but my biggest problem
every day is walking
past the micro kitchen
and not grabbing
something to eat.
And so knowing that
statistic, and being
in the most innovative,
the wealthiest community
in, if not the
country, the world.
We have to be able
to solve this.
This is unacceptable that one in
three children in our community
are hungry.
And so I got to
know Second Harvest,
actually, our team
volunteered there, and sort of
gave me a chance to see how
crazily efficient they are.
I highly recommend that.
It was our favorite off-site.
We go back over and over again.
And also, just
really meeting Kathy
and meeting the organization,
they're such thought leaders.
Kathy basically won the sort
of CEO of food banks nationwide
of the year.
And you can tell from
her stories she really
delivers on that.
I think the thing that has been
most inspiring to me is really,
this is solvable,
particularly given
the resources that we
have as a community.
And so we have an opportunity
to come together and be
the model for all of these
other communities in the nation
and worldwide, and say we're
not OK with this anymore.
We are going to fix it.
And so as Diane mentioned,
the Costco extravaganza
is coming up soon.
It's really fun.
It's really great.
Volunteer with your
teams at Second Harvest.
There's so many ways
to get involved.
But I think we can all agree
that no one in our community
deserves to go
hungry, particularly
when we are so blessed.
DIANE SOLINGER: When we
think about what Googlers
have to offer, we
have our time, we have
our financial resources,
we have our skills,
we have our talents.
So when you think about
some of the big ideas
that maybe your organizations
want to address,
let's kind of take it up to
what could Googler's skills do
to come in and help
make you more efficient,
get to that nobody's
hungry metric
that we're trying to get to.
Any ideas on how
Googlers can help,
besides opening their
wallets, which they do.
ROD BROOKS: Which we're
very grateful for.
So one of the
things that to which
we can attribute that, the
reduction in global hunger,
is that many countries
around the world
have actually made
this a priority.
So in Brazil they've set
a goal of zero hunger.
And there's the Union
of African States
have actually set a goal
of ending hunger by 2025.
That type of commitment
doesn't come about
without awareness of the
issue and an insistence
that we really
treat it that way.
That we make it a priority.
And I'm sure Kathy can
speak that in this country
we've actually been recently
threatened with severe sort
of rips in the safety net that
we have, even in this country.
And in many countries, the
safety nets don't even exist.
So the very first
thing I would say
is that Googlers can
become aware and involved
in this issue.
It takes real advocacy
to make this a priority.
And so that's what I would say
is a very, very real first step
and something that
is very needed.
DIANE SOLINGER: Let
me interject on that,
because right now
the UN is looking
at the next set of
sustainable development goals
that will be developed and
announced next September, 2015.
And we all have an
opportunity as individuals
to go and vote as to what we
think those things should be.
So you can go to myworld.com
or .org-- I don't remember,
one of the two-- myworld,
and you can vote.
And if you think eradicating
hunger should be something
that we focus on,
put your vote in.
And that's one way to help
influence where the UN goes,
which actually helps
governments take a stand
and say, OK, this is something
that we're going to do.
ROD BROOKS: Absolutely.
Beyond that, and something that
Eddy and I were talking about,
so Stop Hunger Now
has, as I described,
traditionally been focused
on first, crisis relief,
but then focusing on
transformational development.
A third area where we
want to be able to do more
is in sustainable
community development,
and that is really
working towards improving
not just the lives, but the
livelihoods of individuals.
And we have been
talking about ways
that we engage so many people
like Googlers in the meal
packaging program, we can
surely leverage those folks'
skills and interests,
and really partnering
with groups like
ORPHANetwork to create
lasting change in
their communities.
And so along with
the opportunity
to package meals with us in six
different meal packaging events
that we have coming up, which
are actually on your flyer,
there's also, we're presenting
the opportunity for you
to become personally engaged
with some of our partners
like ORPHANetwork, there's some
other groups that we work with,
Salesian missions
around the world.
And our goal,
frankly, is to match
those resourced and skilled
individuals with really
passionate visionary
partners that
are working in country who have
a tremendous vision for what
they want to accomplish
on the ground.
And through really putting
those groups together, allowing
you to take the
journey together.
And Eddy, welcome
any ideas that you'd
like to share about,
because you have
ideas about how to improve.
EDDY MORALES: Yeah.
I mean there is a lot,
a lot of opportunities,
I would say, in Nicaragua
when we understand
40% of extreme poverty, 33%
of malnourished children
in Nicaragua, there is
a lot of opportunities.
It's interesting
when you understand
that everything
starts with a meal.
Everything starts here,
what you're doing.
So as Rod said, we
are so thankful.
And understanding
that around a meal,
then, we can add education.
We can wipe out children
having-- girls having baby.
In Nicaragua, 28% of the
girls have their first baby
before 15.
Now, that's a big
issue in Nicaragua
that we have to tackle.
DIANE SOLINGER: Sure.
Takes them out of
school completely.
EDDY MORALES: Exactly.
And then education, as Rod
said, working really hard
for sixth grade,
and we are saying,
no, we want to go
beyond sixth grade.
And then children malnourished.
I mean all of
these issues are, I
would say, just brings great
opportunity to us and to you
to come and to serve.
To serve working with teachers,
working with the children,
working in the communities
where we can just go and take
on a community and
transform that community.
That's possible.
As an orphanage, we are
working really, really hard
to do that, to change a life.
It's not feeding.
It's changing a life.
No, it's producing more J.Los,
it's producing more Leylas,
where--
DIANE SOLINGER: Did
he call you J-Lo?
JENNIFER: Yeah.
EDDY MORALES:
Jennifer Lopez, yeah.
So it's ending that.
And sometime it's even just
sitting with the community
and dreaming with them.
I was sharing with Rod,
I sat with 12 pastors
and said, let's talk
about your community.
Let's talk about assets
in your community.
Probably there is something
that we can take advantage of.
Just put some ideas into
that, ideas that you can bring
and put ideas into that,
and transform the community.
There was a pastor, for
example, who said, oh yeah,
I think my community
needs a library.
We don't have a
bookstore-- library,
bookstore-- I think
I can do that.
I don't need
ORPHANetworks to do that.
Just by sitting and
brainstorming with him.
Seven days after I
went to his community,
he had boxes of books, and he
said, I'm going to set this up.
The children of this
community, my children,
they will have
books, and their life
is going to be
totally different.
It's about changing a life.
And that's what, as
I heard you speaking,
I mean it's not about the food.
It's about changing their life.
And it's interesting,
also, for me,
personally-- when J.Lo
takes over my job,
it's going to be awesome.
But for me, personally,
it's coming from that world
that she was sharing about.
I mean I was
laughing and thinking
I went to school hungry.
I'm one of nine brothers in
the poorest area of Nicaragua.
Grow up.
Many times I went to
school without breakfast.
Many times I came back from
school and mom would say,
I don't have lunch.
Your dad is still
out there fishing,
and I don't have anything.
But Mom was tough.
I usually say Mom was Hitler.
But that was needed
at that time.
She was like, I don't have food!
But you have to study.
And remember, A isn't good.
A+ is acceptable.
But she understood education.
She understood life skills.
She understood we
really need to work hard
in order to get out of poverty.
I remember going to the
convenience store and saying,
can you put that bread
in a plastic bag for me?
And someone would
say oh, this guy-- I
mean he's terrific in hygiene.
No, I wasn't looking for--
I was looking for my school
backpack was that plastic bag.
And understanding
that and see how
because someone was willing
to step up and help me,
because someone was
willing to say yes, I
want to make a difference in
someone's life-- oh, Eddy--
and how my life
changed from there,
I mean I just can't stop
giving back to others.
I just understand food
is the opportunity.
Just the beginning point of
change in so many people's
lives, just as so many
people did it for me
and took me out of
extreme poverty.
And I'm not poor anymore today.
And I will never.
My life is changed.
My child life will
be totally different.
But someone was willing to
step up and say yes, I'm
going to make a
difference in Eddy's life.
Now, you can be
that person to make
a difference in
someone else's life.
That's what we're
teaching our children
in our six orphanages,
350 children.
Our seventh goal is
go and find J.Lo two.
Go and find J.Lo three.
Go and find J.Lo four.
They're out there.
They're waiting for you, and
go and make a difference.
DIANE SOLINGER:
Leyla's right here.
She's J.Lo too.
EDDY MORALES: Leyla.
DIANE SOLINGER: So Kathy,
data-driven systems,
efficiencies, all those things--
that's just Google, right?
KATHY JACKSON: Yeah.
DIANE SOLINGER: So
how can Googlers
get more involved
with the food bank?
KATHY JACKSON: Well,
it's one of the reasons
that we're so excited that
Suzanne is on the board
because she can play this
fantastic translational role.
Because she already
speaks-- I don't know,
what do you call it?
Googlese or whatever.
She knows what you guys do and
can break it down and put it
into simple words
of one syllable
that we at the food bank
can actually understand.
But she's now achieving
a different language
which is food bankese.
And I think she's going to
be really helpful in terms
of finding ways, identifying
things where your expertise is
right in the center
of the bullseye.
We have barely scratched
the surface, you guys,
in terms of figuring out
how to use technology
to remove barriers that exist
for people to find food.
And as several folks have
said, there is enough food.
My god, here in America,
we waste 40% of the food.
So talk about it's in the
wrong place, my goodness.
If we could capture
a fraction of that
and connect it with
the people who need it,
there's some
technology in there.
There are apps in
there that could
be incredibly helpful to us.
I don't know what they are,
but I know that they're there,
and it would be so
fun and so exciting.
And I will share,
we're in the process
of doing a pilot with a
little tiny middle school.
We're interviewing--
it's only 120 families.
We're interviewing, doing deep
interviews with 60, at least,
of those families.
And one of the things
that we learned is that--
and these are truly
the working poor.
Every single household
has someone working,
but they can't make ends meet.
North of 90% of those
people have not cell phones,
smartphones.
OK, now I start to get very
excited in thinking about ways
we could use technology
to connect people
with the nutritious food that
they so desperately need.
So I'm really
hopeful-- Suzanne, you
didn't know I was
going to say all this.
But Suzanne is going
to-- you should see her
in our board meeting.
She's like "There's
an app for that.
We could do something
about that."
DIANE SOLINGER: Those are
skilled-based projects
that we'd like to source and
get input from organizations,
both you and other
organizations that how can
we leverage Googler skills.
But we need that
internal champion.
And I know both of
you, with Suzanne
and with a couple of
folks here who are really
involved with Stop
Hunger Now, I think
it's the internal
champion to help
rally the troops around that.
So we have some great first date
opportunities in volunteering.
Coming up, we have food
packing events with Stop Hunger
Now all over the place.
EDDY MORALES: And I was just
thinking that someone just
donated a computer lab to us.
One of our orphanage
with 25 computer.
It's probably the best
computer lab in Nicaragua.
Someone donated
from Virginia Beach.
So I mean we're here thinking
what can we do with this.
One thing we know we want to
do, take advantage of this
and improve the education
of our children.
You can come and look at it
and tell us how to improve.
How to take advantage
of these 25 computer.
From Virginia Beach someone
is even sitting and looking
at the children
learning computer.
DIANE SOLINGER: That's awesome.
EDDY MORALES: It's awesome.
So you can come and see
and just help us just
improving our education, the
education for our children,
how they can learn
online, how they
can learn English to make a
difference in their lives.
Knowing all of this.
So that's great.
I mean you can come
with me next Sunday
to see the computer lab and--
DIANE SOLINGER: Got a trip
planned for everybody.
It's awesome.
But yeah, think about those.
The first date opportunities
are coming up with the food
packing events for Stop Hunger
Now with the extravaganza here
in Mountain View that
Alan will be hosting
probably the first
week of December.
Also, we're organizing for
Googlers on the Quad campus
in Mountain View, an off-site
packing event at the food bank.
So I think those are great
first date opportunities.
If you go to the go link for
the Hunger Relief Campaign,
it's Go Give For Hunger.
You'll scroll down and
there are local volunteering
opportunities already there
with many organizations
in our communities.
Many of them are distribution
partners of Second Harvest Food
Bank, like the Sunnyvale
Community Services and Mountain
View CSA.
But think about what you can do
for that, maybe that first date
experience.
And then when you're there,
open up your mind a little bit
and think hmm,
maybe this could be
run a little bit
differently, or maybe
if I got a group of
Googlers together
and we've got expertise
in this, that,
that we could maybe
help this organization
in a different way, a
little bit more deeply.
Don't have to necessarily
join the board like Suzanna
did, which is awesome
and we love that, too,
but think about what you
can do as a small group.
We also have a program
called Google Reach
Local which is
running this week.
We have a variety of
hunger-related and poverty
alleviation organizations
here in the Bay area,
and that's a week-long
program with cohorts
of Googlers going in and doing
pro bono consulting, really
on systems and
operational efficiencies,
organizational development
for the organizations.
So those opportunities
will come up too,
and you can apply for
those when those pop up.
But think about not
just that first date,
but what you can do.
Another thing, since we're
going to need to wrap-up
is that you can donate.
So the Go Give For
Hunger link will take you
the global campaign that the
[INAUDIBLE] team is really
behind, which is focused
on action against hunger.
Really getting kids off
the brink of starvation
and getting them to a more
stable place in their life
where they can maybe take
advantage of a Stop Hunger Now
program, or working more
with their local food banks.
But this is really on
the edge of starvation.
And then at the back
of the room here, we
have an opportunity for you
to donate to Stop Hunger Now
and to Second Harvest Food Bank.
Actually, right now across the
US and soon across the world,
people are having
opportunity to put forth
their favorite organizations
for the G-Gift campaign, which
will be the first
week of December.
So if you're
passionate about hunger
and you want to put forth
one of these organizations
or a hunger-related organization
that you care about,
as an organization
you'd like to help raise
money for during G-Give,
you can do that now.
So there's lots ways to
help, and we hope you will.
And hope you keep the
conversation going forward
about what we can
do as a company,
as individuals, as a group
of Googlers to get to zero.
Nobody should have
to worry about food.
We should make that a
good goal for our company
and for ourselves.
Thanks, everybody.
KATHY JACKSON: Thank you.
DIANE SOLINGER: Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]